- [Tutor] The Bill of
Rights, as we know it today
were the first 10 amendments
to the Constitution
and these amendments
guaranteed individual liberty
to make sure that citizens
had stated expectation
for what the government
could or could not do to them
and you can kind of see here
in many of these rights,
the legacy of the Revolutionary War
and the kinds of government abuses,
that citizens in the Colonies had feared.
Now I'm going to go
over these very quickly,
we'll spend a lot more
time in other videos
talking more about these amendments,
but I wanna give you an overall sense
of what they're driving at.
Now the first four amendments
guarantee individual liberties,
these are freedom of religion,
speech, press, assembly,
freedom to ask the government
for redress of grievances
or to deal with a problem,
that the government may
have caused in your life,
the right to bear arms
and assemble militias,
state and local militias had
made the Revolutionary War
a success for the United States,
a ban on quartering soldiers in homes,
recall that the Quartering Act,
when the British government
said that the Colonies
had to put up soldiers in their homes
was a major driver of revolution
and a ban on unreasonable
search and seizure,
that is it would be necessary
for the government to get a warrant
to enter your home or to
search your belongings.
The next four amendments
in the Bill of Rights
deal with protections for
people accused of crimes
and again, you see the legacy
of the Revolutionary War
and the idea that the Crown
had had too much power
to persecute individuals,
so this includes things like
the right to due process,
that is to make sure that all the steps
of following the law are taken,
a ban on being tried
twice for the same crime,
rights to a speedy and public trial,
a jury of your peers, to
even have a jury in cases,
that don't have to do with violent crimes,
but rather civil disputes
and a ban on excessive bail
and cruel and unusual punishment,
basically this is a guarantee
that the government will respect
the rights of individuals.
Now, one of the arguments made against
including a Bill of
Rights in the Constitution
was that listing out those rights
might then mean that
they were the only rights
and that by listing out
these rights in particular,
they might be forfeiting
their liberties in other ways,
so the ninth and tenth amendments
attempt to deal with that worry,
they say in the ninth amendment,
any right that isn't listed here
is still retained by the people,
so this is not an exhaustive list,
this is not the complete list
of all the rights retained by the people
and the tenth amendment
is slightly different,
but kind of on the same line,
they say that if this Constitution
has not delegated a right
directly to the federal government,
then that right is reserved
to the states or the people,
so the federal government can only do
the things that are listed
in this Constitution,
it is a limited government,
limited by this document.
On the other hand, the rights
of the people are unlimited,
so if the Constitution doesn't say
that the federal government can do it,
that's then a right of
the states or the people.